all right Sergio
hello Sergio
um where are you from originally where'd
you grow up originally I was born in
South America uh came to the United
States when I was very young um touched
down in Aurora Colorado
and then grew up there to the age of
fourth grade and then came here to Los
Angeles
you're not uh you're not Latin American
you are full Korean um just have the
Spanish first name because there's like
this tradition in my family where all
the males get like Hispanic first names
like my dad's name was Antonio my
uncle's name was Roberto so I guess they
named me Sergio
that you're not Hispanic not Hispanic
just full Korean and uh how would you
describe your childhood
I would say my childhood was pretty
normal up until the fourth grade
um even though I did have some stuff
happened to me
pre-fifth grade because I had some nasty
things happen to me from my cousins that
I don't really want to get into too much
I also
have
I was raised the only child so that was
pretty tough I'm pretty lonely most of
the time and
uh when I came to Los Angeles when it
got really weird for sure
with what what I mean just be vague
about like sexual abuse yeah we could
say that okay yeah
and uh
what kind of give you in high school
in high school I was already struggling
so up until fourth grade I was getting
pretty good grades and then once I got
to middle school I started struggling
not with the academics but really just
paying attention and I was just had a
really hard time just sitting down and
by the time I hit High School I already
dropped out by freshman year because I
was having a really hard time just you
know with the with school in general it
just really wasn't really for me
you finished high school I didn't I got
a GED okay yeah so instead of I didn't
get the diploma but I got a GED while I
was um incarcerated
before
um but at that time I was in for a
commercial burglary and that was in my
juvenile years
were there drugs involved in your life
then yeah for sure because I was already
doing drugs by the time I was like 15
years old yeah how'd you first get
introduced
so basically
um
I was self-medicating because in high
school I had I was going through this
breakup and
I didn't really have anybody to talk to
about my relationship issues because
well I had a language barrier with my
mom I was growing up here I couldn't
really speak Korean that well and she
didn't speak English too well so I had a
hard time and while I was going through
this breakup I started experimenting
with weed started smoking it pretty
heavily eventually uh moved on to stuff
like ecstasy cocaine and then eventually
landed on methamphetamine
that was your main drug main drug of
choice for sure methamphetamine is Xanax
in your childhood back to that is
stereotypical
Asian or Korean family
wouldn't really you would you wouldn't
picture a drug addict being in the
family
no um I didn't expect it at all because
like I said I had a pretty normal
childhood but
after fifth grade not really because
what happened was my dad
me my mom and my dad were in the picture
and then when I went to middle school my
dad suffered an injury at the workplace
and he had to be hospitalized in
Colorado
so when he was in Colorado
I was living with my mom alone here and
she was a single mother I'm the only
child she's at work most of the time so
she couldn't really control me
and while I was just doing my thing
there was no supervision my dad wasn't
in the picture anymore and I was the
only child and I was just
doing whatever I wanted basically
and that's where some of the abuse came
the abuse that's where the abuse kind of
snuck in the for drug abuse no the uh
sexual abuse no no no no the sexual
abuse was when I was a child yeah but
that's not typical for a nation family
or is it I don't know I don't know I
never
um I don't know because like a lot of
families don't really want to talk about
stuff that goes down when it comes to
like uncles or cousins
um and I thought it was
strange but I didn't know how strange it
was until I got older and
I never really spoke about this to
anybody before so it's kind of like
getting to me a little bit I'm like
feeling the pressure right now but
yeah
the sexual abuse and then this is pretty
insignificant but when I was a child
I had a bike stolen from me and
after that
I started stealing stuff too for no
reason even though I had stuff my mom
was buying me the things I needed
um
I had generally had everything I needed
to grow up properly but for some reason
I started just taking things that
weren't mine I started stealing stuff
from school I came back my mom would
find these this set of dice that I stole
and she beat me up for it beat my butt
for it but
I guess I never learned my lesson and I
guess that's why I eventually ended up
in
juvenile hall and L.A county jail
because of
me stealing stuff
you think that was just some form of
acting out from what you were yeah I
believe it was some sort of acting out
um because by the time I got here to La
um I'm not going to say that we were
poor but my mom was definitely you know
struggling being a single parent here in
LA and we didn't have much I'm not going
to say we had nothing but it was just
the typical living living in Koreatown
your parents separated or your dad so my
dad when he got hospitalized they
weren't completely separated but the
reason why he went back to Colorado was
because that's where his side of the
family was and at the time my mom is
here alone there's no family here
besides my mom and my uncle so my dad
had to get family support they weren't
broken up though they were still
together at the time but eventually they
drifted apart from being separated for
so long because my dad
never got better after he got that
injury and he eventually passed away and
that's kind of what made my drug use go
from
casual to like completely off the walls
you don't hear of a whole lot of Asians
like here on Skid Row you don't see like
there's
I've seen maybe three Asian people in in
the 12 years I've spent down here almost
13 years 13 years there's not a whole
lot of Asians that are involved in drugs
but I mean what's been your experience
so I didn't getting to Skid Row was
definitely a journey it didn't just
happen overnight um I was doing the
drugs I eventually left my house when I
was 18 years old so what happened was I
got incarcerated for that commercial
burglary went to juvenile hall did eight
months got out of camp but while I was
in Camp my dad had passed away and my
mom didn't tell me that and when I got
out she said hey I didn't want to tell
you this while you were in jail
but your dad passed away and while you
were in and he couldn't come you know
so that hit me really hard and I turned
18 in Camp so by the time I got out I
was ready to just
be free and be an 18 year old kid but my
mom hit me with the news that my dad had
just died and that we had to go to a
funeral
and I'm not gonna lie I did not go to
the funeral I wasn't ready to face
whatever emotions
that I had to face and that is when I
started
shooting meth because at the until up
until that point I was only smoking it
and when I found out that my dad had
passed and I hit the streets and I just
wanted to get as
messed up and high as I could and
I've seeked out this acquaintance I knew
that already was dabbling with shooting
up an intravenous use and I had him come
by and he showed me how to do it and
that pretty much started the speed run
to Skid Row I was homeless left my mom's
house living on the streets couch couch
surfing living in abandoned apartments
or sleeping on the Subways and just
pretty much always losing my stuff
because people would go through my
pockets while I was asleep in public
so that's the one reason why I really
like the meth because I didn't have to
sleep at night because I could literally
just like find a place to sleep during
the day which is generally a little bit
safer like homeless centers drop-in
centers and then I would just try to
stay up at night as best as I could
because that was when it was really
dangerous especially here in Skid Row
but but your drug use kind of stemmed
from trying to deal with
my dad passing my relationship issues I
just never dealt with my emotions and
eventually it just snowballed and
snowballed and the reason why I ended up
on Skid Row in the first place was
because there was a needle exchange here
and there was no way for me to actually
get clean or new needles because I was
homeless in the attics so I would come
here to Skid Row and I met this other
Asian guy his name was Brandon I'm not
going to say his last name but he's the
one that showed me the needle exchange
and that's when I started kind of just
hanging out around here because it was
the most convenient the cops weren't
really bothering me and
that's just how it went you can sleep
anywhere you like I sleep anywhere I
like you know no one really bothering me
too much and it was
definitely an eye-opening experience
there's um
I used to like go inside of these like
porta potty those metal porta potties
that have the sliding doors and just do
my business in there and come out and
just
you know do my thing and yeah
your life has changed a lot since then
though oh drastically after well let me
how many how many years were you living
like that uh so I was on the street
since 18 for sure I was doing it for at
least two years straight because I
didn't get incarcerated until I was
about 20 years old because while I was
um out on the streets I needed money and
I committed a residential burglary and
um that landed me in jail that actually
got a a strike for it I got a felony on
my record for that and when I got out
they were supposed to send me to prison
but they instead I told them look I have
a I have a problem I need help and they
sent me to a rehab so
long story short I left that rehab
relapsed again and then got locked up
they gave me a second chance went back
to rehab finished the program graduated
got off probation
got a regular job one of my first
regular paying jobs and I just started
working the regular nine to five and
then met my wife and
a lot of things have changed
what do you what do you credit that
those changes to
while I was in rehab and
just going through the months and I
slowly started to just have things of my
own I got my license I saved up for a
car I had my own clothes and they were
telling me about an apartment program so
I was like wow so as soon as I started
getting these things that I could call
my own it motivated me to see how far I
could go with it eventually got my
apartment and of course
I still relapse after I got clean but I
feel like that's a part of recovery and
as long as you don't slip back into it
that's all that matters
but it was was your therapy involved or
anything like that
no so there was not much therapy
involved um you had a lot of emotional
baggage to emotional baggage for sure so
that's where
so the rehab that I went to they were
very work-centric and they would they
had us doing a lot of Labor and keeping
us busy
um and I'm not sure that is exactly what
I needed but it worked and I've pretty
much learned how to hold down a stable
job and work hard and be grateful for
what I had
but
I want to say
I was really just sick and tired of
being on the streets and I was really
relieved to just have finally found
just the normal life that I could live
and just tried to stick to it my oh I
cannot forget to give my mom some credit
because she's the one that showed up to
every court date she continued to
support me through rehab and without her
I don't know where I would be for sure
that's usually what what it takes is
just being fed up with your own
BS yeah yeah it takes
and you know what sometimes a lot of
those people a lot of people don't hit
rock bottom as and I feel like you
really need to hit rock bottom in order
to wake up but what's scary is that
I feel like
I'm not trying to get political or
anything but I feel like they make it
kind of hard for you to actually hit
rock bottom here in America I don't know
if that's going to be controversial to
say but because they give out like
clothing food housing yeah and I'm not
saying that's a fast change yeah yeah
I'm not saying that's a bad thing
because yeah sure harm reduction and
everything but
it makes it kind of comfortable not
comfortable but a little bit easier too
yeah you can get arrested for using
right okay yeah and it's just
like I don't for I'm not going to
disclose why but I don't qualify for
certain things like EBT and food stamps
and Welfare and stuff so that pretty
much like accelerated my sick and
tiredness but I feel like a lot of
people
do have a lot of things here even when
you're homeless and the government
support government support the they call
it GS uh gr government relief government
relief okay and all the food stamps and
all the things there
right handing out regularly right and
I'm not saying I'm not trying to say
that's a bad thing I'm not saying that
we shouldn't take care of these people
it's just what I've noticed for myself
was that if I had those things I don't
know if I would have woken up so soon I
mean yes I'm still young I'm 26 years
old and I'm glad that I got sober
before it's too late because there's
some irreversible damages that could
happen and I feel like
I really dodged the bullet for sure you
got away from fentanyl I got away from
fentanyl yeah so what when I was doing
drugs I wasn't around when you were that
was not a thing I didn't even know what
that was you know and like nowadays when
I walk around when I drove here I saw a
lot of people slumped out and just like
sitting down they're in their tents back
when I was in skid row everybody was
moving around because I feel like eight
out of the ten people were high on
either some type of amphetamine or not
Fentanyl and it just seems like
there used to be heroin crack and maybe
speed right now it's just all fit and
now it's 80 80 at least 80 fentanyl it's
it's wild to see and it's it's a scary
time because it's not just the people
that are here that are affected it's
everybody that could be in your cocaine
bag it can be in a pill I had a friend
die last month from taking this pill and
it was fentanyl yeah and it's just that
was in pills I've heard they're even
lacing pot with it now pot wow that's I
did not hear about that but who knows
yeah no it's a scary time to be an
addict for sure
you have Asian friends I do have Asian
friends are our drugs kind of a thing
with them oh yeah yeah so when I was
growing up in Koreatown
everybody was on some type of ecstasy or
cocaine party drugs methamphetamine not
so much it was it kind of had like a
stigma like oh you're smoking meth but
it's um like there was a lot of
stimulants involving Asians they love
Raves and stuff like that so I mean
ecstasy was definitely a thing
and I've I've watched some of my friends
and people that I knew go down the same
path as me and they're part of the
reason
that intrigued me about it was there is
this one age Korean rehab in Koreatown
and I think it's like the only Korean
rehab and it's a faith-based uh like a
service and they pretty much have you do
Christian stuff Bible studies and stuff
like that but when I when one of my
friends got there
she had mentioned that there was people
there that have been there for eight to
ten years and it's like
okay you know that's a good thing sure
you've been sober for eight to ten years
but I feel like at some point there
needs to be like a transition for them
to move back into society and
there's not a lot of that because in in
the Asian Community people want to act
like drug use doesn't exist and it's
almost like completely frowned upon and
you don't want to bring up that you have
a drug problem because I don't know if a
lot of first generation second
generation Asian parents would
understand before just kicking them out
completely or disowning them because
it's just so strict and I was blessed to
have a mom
that was not really like that but
I've watched a lot of my friends go
through homelessness and getting kicked
out of the house or leaving the house
because their the parents aren't going
to seek help for their kids or not
saying all parents are going to do that
but a lot of Asian parents are pretty
hard on them very strict you know kick
them to the curb learn your hard lessons
whatever the case is right
what would you say was your lowest point
when you were
you're using my lowest point was when I
snuck back into my mom's apartment but
she was she had already moved out and
she told me that I couldn't come back I
snuck back in and there was this
abandoned unit in the basement where
like the worker kept all of his like
work stuff
and I slept down there for a couple of
days and it was super Dusty in there so
my
I got really dirty I shaved my head I
was completely bald and
I pretty much burned all my bridges at
that point because I was stealing from
whoever it didn't matter whether if it
was friends or whether if it was people
that people I didn't know and I burned
all my bridges
and at that point I fell extra alone my
mom was not helping me out and I had no
friends and I was just trying to figure
it out and
I feel like being alone in your
addiction is probably one of the worst
things you can do because then you just
sink deeper and deeper with no one to
tell you Behavior changes so drastically
that you just become alienated from
everyone exactly exactly and I just felt
like an outcast and
um
I know you know I did say that I had a
lot of friends that did drugs like my
Asian friends but there were a lot of
Asian friends that went to college
universities and I seen the Facebook
pictures and you just see that stuff and
you just feel like a complete failure
and you just like thinking like man like
these are people
my peers and they're out here you know
UCLA USC UC Irvine and
I'm just here you know and that was a
hard pill to swallow feeling like I had
essentially Fallen back and
felt like I was in the Rat Race that I
couldn't
ever get a head on and
um
getting to Skid Row sleeping on the
streets was definitely one of my lowest
moments for sure before then I it was
relatively okay because I had like
couches to sleep on and stuff but
yeah I would say my darkest
by far would be
the last two months before getting
incarcerated for the residential
burglary because
I I was already aware that I had a
warrant for my arrest because
there's a long story behind that
residential burglary well basically okay
I'm gonna I already told the story
before but I was I will tell it again so
how will this residential burglary went
down was I was dating this girl at the
time before I met this girl
my friend of mine told me hey I want to
go burglarize this house so I said sure
let's go and once once we finished up
with that we did our thing we got out
um I didn't know the owner of the house
and then two or three months later I
meet this chick and we started talking
my a mutual friend introduced us and
turns out that chick's ex-boyfriend was
the house that I had burglarized and
she started putting two and two together
but I never really told her anything
definitive and eventually I don't know
exactly what happened to this day but
all of a sudden they had alerted her
that there was a felony warrant for my
arrest and she told me that they were
looking for me and that's when I was
like extremely paranoid and
essentially it felt like a drug-induced
schizophrenic episode I was hearing
voices and I felt like everybody was
looking at me when they drove by and it
was just I feel like it was like the
closest thing to a psychotic break for
sure now that you're clean and you've
been clean for a while do you look back
at that
part of your life and just
wonder what you're
how you got there yeah no I I think back
and
it almost doesn't feel real like it
almost feels like a dream and it feels
like it didn't happen
um but when I look back at it now it
almost all makes sense like the whole
relationship thing not being able to
talk to my parents I understand what
happened
um
I'm just grateful to be here now doing
this interview with you with my good
health and you know things to look
forward to
yeah I'm glad you're doing better thank
you
Sergeant what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned after
all of this the most important lesson
that I've learned through all of this
is to stay focused on whatever it is
that you're doing and you even if you're
not seeing results right away in
whatever it is that you're doing just
to be aware that things are coming as
long as you stay focused and on the
right path and I feel like a lot of
these blessings that I have now
um wouldn't have came if I didn't just
stay focused and stay on the right path
because now I'm getting to work one of
my dream careers and what are you doing
now I'm doing what you do rather but not
on the scale of what you do um so you
and that's part of the reason why your
channel will intrigued me so much
because I started a YouTube channel
because I felt like I went through the
things that I went through because
I needed to tell my story and I took all
my stories to YouTube
finding little success in it nowhere
near Yours Like I said but it's just a
blessing that I'm able to make most of
my money on a platform that I've watched
since I was a kid I've grew I grew up
watching YouTube I didn't have cable so
I was really like you know internet kid
and just when I came across your Channel
and I saw what you were doing as far as
like the attic interviews and giving
these essentially faceless people a
voice
um
it resonated with me because that's
something that I wanted to do for like
you know
um addicts but of like not just Asians
but I wanted to highlight the addictions
that Asian people face and that what a
lot of people don't talk about
excellent
Sergio thank you so much for sharing
your story of course I'm glad you're
doing better thank you and stay on track
thank you brother thank you man